hey guys I'm Eric Voss and this is a
breakdown of Sherlock series 4 episode 2
the line detective and spoiler alert if
you haven't watched it yet but thank god
Sherlock is a show that uses clues and
visual trickery to disguise its reveal
because otherwise I think we'd all have
no excuse for not noticing the scheme
based on three different characters as
always we see but we do not observe or
do we observe but not see anyway just
like last episode the six thatcher's I'm
going to point out all the subtle
miscible details the winks to the
original Arthur Conan Doyle short
stories and all the work this episode
did to set up this huge reveal so let's
get started with the opening images so
the first thing we see is this gunshot
which we've seen in the new series for
opening credits now obviously the final
scene of this episode reveals who's
holding this smoking gun but this
opening sequence already sneaks in a few
clues for one notice how John is framed
here in a horizontal profile shot as the
camera pans down obviously this is one
of the shows many impressionistic
transitions indicating that John right
here is in a totally different location
than where the gun is laying awake at
night in his bedroom haunted by another
gunshot that killed his wife Mary but
another way to look at this is framing
John this way implies that he is in
another specific location where we see
him seconds later a place where John
would lie on his back and express his
grief to a therapist so putting this all
together the therapist is the shooter
also another clue check out this rug
that's in the therapists office it looks
like a spreading puddle of blood on the
floor between her and John so who has
two rug like that obviously this is
meant to catch our eye bad things are
going to go down in this location but
there are some other subtle things that
this scene does to give us even more
information about the therapist
specifically a connection between her
and Sherlock so notice how John and the
therapist sit in the same placement that
John and Sherlock do in their flat on
Baker Street with John on the left and
Sherlock and a therapist on the right
also the therapist notices John's eyes
wandering to look at Mary and she says
this line I tend to notice these things
I'm sure now I am reminding you of a
friend I think now in this moment we're
just meant to think of her as a really
perceptive therapist who can tell that
John Michell Sherlock but no we
the reveal later this woman is literally
a female counterpart of Sherlock with
the same sociopathic and perceptive
tendencies that all the Holmes kids have
and the fact that Sherlock has been so
adamant lately that in other cases it's
never true that kind of makes me think
that these two might have ended up
sharing a womb at some point and before
I move on I just want to point out how
amazing Shaun Brooke is in her various
roles in these episodes Brooke actually
played opposite Benedict Cumberbatch as
Ophelia in their recent staging of
Shakespeare's Hamlet and I know that
some more perceptive viewers were like
hey that's obviously the same woman but
I was fooled and I think that's a
product of Brookes mastery of accents
and mannerisms as a performer as well as
amazing makeup and hair and costuming by
the crew but another thing that
disguises this is the way that she is
shot and edited so like notice how and
pretty much all of her scenes until the
end
Brooke is shot at an angle with the
light catching her glasses and her hair
more than her facial features often at a
focus and at a distance while the focus
is really on the other character in the
scene and each time the camera cuts to
her we cut away before we can really get
a good look at her now I'll talk more
about this kind of clever camerawork
later on but let's move on to the
introduction of this episode's villain
culverton Smith played by Toby Jones now
if you're watching in the UK you might
have recognized some parallels between
Smith and Jimmy Savile he was another
eccentric British TV personality with
some powerful connections in the
government he was actually knighted and
he allegedly abused children in hospital
wards so he definitely seems to be at
least a loose inspiration for this
version of Culberson Smith now of course
covert in Smith was the villain in the
Arthur Conan Doyle short story this
episode was based on the adventure of
the dying detective where Holmes makes
himself extremely ill in order to trap
Smith who confesses his murder to dying
people on I'll point out other
similarities as ago now the drug that
they use tv12 interferes with people's
memories and this kind of sci-fi drug
with mentally debilitating effects does
have some precedent the short stories
they show up in the adventure of the
creeping man and the adventure of the
devil foot okay moving on as we
transition from basic Smith hazy
drug-induced memory to her and Sherlock
on Baker Street again the ending does an
amazing job to disguise the fact that
has been played by two different actors
it means these sequence of phase writing
a note extorts our perception of her
face which we hardly got a good look of
anyway and all this leads to Sherlock's
line that neatly explains away any
physical changes to her appearance you
changed on the topic eternity roots of
showings I think it's okay and also the
camerawork and blocking keep up this
illusion with face facing away from us
at the start transitioning from far away
out of focus and gradually come in more
and more interview until finally we just
become accustomed to this version of
faith and like Sherlock we accept her as
the real thing
and in case you're wondering how
Sherlock could spend an entire evening
with a woman and not realize that she's
not only the wrong person put his sister
keep in mind Sherlock is super high
right now making him still able to use
his deductive powers but distorting his
ability to see the reality right in
front of him in other words he observed
but he doesn't see and remember Sherlock
has had a blind spot for fellow
Psychopaths like with Moriarty posing as
Molly's boyfriend in the great game and
the cab driver in a study in pink also I
should point out that a lot of these
story elements are inspired from the
short stories as well with Holmes
cocaine addiction showing up in the sign
of the four the five orange pips the man
with the twisted lip and the yellow face
also Holmes trying to work out an
unknown person sentenced to death
happens in the valley of fear and then
notice when Sherlock says this line come
on snow you're on keep your hands off
that line is taken directly from the
adventure of the lion's mane where home
sees that a female client is planning to
commit suicide and he has to talk her
down which is exactly what he thinks
he's doing with face in this episode we
also get a few references to Steven
Moffat others show Doctor Who so like
the book that face hides the folded note
inside is written by Lavinia Smith she's
the odds of Sarah Jane Smith in the
classic Doctor Who but in the more
recent version Moffat wrote an episode
called the beasts below in which
characters voluntarily erase their
memories just like in this episode of
Sherlock but moving on to these two
siblings and maybe twins adorably
strolling through the streets of London
and I love this line from fake fake
babies let's see you now obviously this
is a reference to George Orwell's 1984
with face comparing Mycroft surveillance
to the authoritarian society in that
book but also this is another clue scoop
because faith is talking about
my crops here who is literally her
interlocked big brother we also get this
amazing visual sequence of Sherlock
reconstructing fake face fake flats from
nothing but the sun damage to the piece
of paper deducing from that the angle of
the sunlight and the distance of the
wall and it all feels like an annoying
high school geometry problem but like
visually engaging it actually has the
feel of that Paris scene and in session
with Cobb and Ariadne similarly using
this purple crayon technique to draw the
world around them and manipulating it to
make a point and again all of this is
designed as a misdirect to keep
attention on Sherlock and his
fascinating thought process and away
from face appearance and her true
identity now throughout this episode
various shots of covert and Smith are
spliced in footage from commercial
Britain's Got Talent style show with him
as a judge and interviews and the
purpose of this editing is to reinforce
Sherlock's paranoia over a person this
evil being able to hide in plain sight
however one mysterious insert comes in
the middle of the sequence with faith
where Koval and Smith says you should be
cast out to burn a bridge now all the
other Clips we Steve Smith's are pretty
straightforward double entendres of him
saying that no I'm a Killa or hitting
the button and saying Gilles meanwhile
burning bridges is a phrase that means
like severing ties and business or
personal relationships
so why include a random shot of Smith's
giving some business advice so this
leads me to a theory prediction that I
have for next episode so it's good to
this time if you don't want to know
anything about it so I think this is a
bit of a shot in the dark but I think
this reference to Bridges is going to be
important so if you saw the trailer for
episode 3 the final problem there is
kind of a cheesy shot with Sherlock and
John jumping from a massive explosion
and I'm wondering if this is a burning
bridge that culverton Smith was alluding
to and we might see some other kind of
great game for a Moriarty that involves
like London Bridge falling down or
blowing up
now the sequence of Sherlock producing
the word anyone is brilliantly edited to
show Sherlock's inverted perspective on
details to arrive at the truth he
revisits his previous locations now
shown from a new angle and even a new
line' with Molly Mary and face all
saying the word anyone also an inverted
color shot of the word someone from the
note a reconstruction of Smith's
boardroom and his Baker Street flat
literally inverted on its side which
they had to construct a special rotating
set forth and the YouTuber nerdwriter
did an amazing analysis of the sequence
that you should definitely check out if
you haven't already but one thing I
appreciate about the way the sequence in
is notice how Sherlock collapses onto
the sofa with his head shoved into a
pillow made of tweed which is the same
material that his iconic beer Starkel
beer Starkel deerstalker beer skulker
hat is made out of so i know i might be
forcing this but i just like how a
version of Sherlock hat pops onto his
head at the precise moment that he makes
this big realization okay moving on past
one of my favorite twists ever on the
show that mrs. Hudson is behind the
wheel of this beating Aston Martin to
this moment with Sherlock ranting and
raving and his flat full conspiracy
theorists and his lines here are from
Shakespeare's Henry the fifth so other
than giving benedict cumberbatch a
chance to show off his figs beer and
reveal the origin of the game is on okay
this quote is actually very fitting
because it's considered one of the best
descriptions on what it's like to go to
war and Sherlock is facing going to war
with culverton Smith and Sherlock's
shooting the wall is a reference to the
short story the Musgrave ritual where
home fires is revolver in the wall to
create the initials VR for Victoria
Regina the Queen of England or the
Victoria name also I should point out
that mrs. Hudson interfering and forcing
Watson to meet with home is another
thing that happens in the dining
detective short story moving on to
Sherlock coming face to face with
culverton Smith after accusing him
publicly of being a serial killer and a
lot of you are asking how exactly Smith
is hiding in plain sight like he has all
these punny media spots a commercial
where he says I'm a serial killer a
magazine headline that reads you
wouldn't believe the things they let me
get away with you wrote a book titled
how to make a killing he's a host of a
show called business killer and a touch
brave is
and yeah all this does seem super
obvious and over-the-top but I think
that's the point
this is culverton Smith public persona
he naturally comes off and kind of a
creepy serial killer so he holds it and
plays that up so that no one actually
takes it seriously this is his kind of
brilliant version of hiding in plain
sight now visiting the hospital for
charity is another plot point taken
directly from the short story but check
out Miz hospital it's called Saints head
Wallace
now said Walla was a prolific killer who
repented before he died and he's
considered the patron saint of Tyrael
killers man they got a patron saint for
everything also this shows production
designer pointed out that the logo for
this hospital was designed in such a way
to both look like someone caring for
another person if you look at the light
part of a plot if you look at the dark a
spooky spooky face so just like Overton
Smith set up this hospital under the
guise of healthy people when in reality
he's Pookie also notice how this woman
named nurse Cornish is brutally honest
with John about the blog content Hanuman
this is a reference to a real-life
experience of Arthur Conan Doyle where a
Cornish boatman rode him across the
river and upon realizing that Conan
Doyle wrote the truck home stories he
said it wasn't necessary came back from
the date good cockney right so nurse
Cornish is a tribute to Conan Doyle's
first real critic okay moving on to
Sherlock talking to the sick children
where we get a few more references to
the short stories Sherlock sprays the
eye on change of reasoning is a common
expression that Holmes uses in a Study
in Scarlet and six Napoleon in the story
of Lexington the poisonous is a wink to
the resident patient and the Greek his
house reference is a radio play where
everyone locked in a house tried to
murder one victim and then final age
bakusaiga time it could be a reference
to a couple things the adventure of the
creepy man where professor ingested
monkey glands and becomes homicidal or
the Edgar Allan Poe detective story the
murderers of room Wars Arthur Conan
Doyle listed Poe as a huge influence on
his writing moving on once it becomes
clear that culverton Smith is an actual
murderous monster he brings up a th
Holmes as a favorite serial killer now
it's a coincidence that he shares his
last name with Sherlock but Holmes was
infamous he killed upwards of 200 people
stalking them at the World's Fair in
Chicago and bringing them back through
his own murder castle which was a
three-story building with
Admiral of rooms and weirdly shaped
hallways and hidden doors and Smith
reveals later on that he went through
several architects so that only he would
know the complete layout of the hospital
and all of its hidden doors which is
exactly what Holmes did when
constructing his murder castle this is
also something that reportedly it's
happened to famous architects throughout
history with Ivan the Terrible of Russia
blinding the architects who built Saint
Basil's Cathedral and Shah Jahan cutting
off the hands of the architects and
builders of the Taj Mahal so all of you
architects out there maybe keep your
work nice and mediocre now in my
breakdown at the six Thatcher's I
speculated that the post-credit line
from merry go to hell Sherlock seem to
have more to it judging from how dead
serious merry sounded and this episode
sheds more light on that with an
extended version that explains why
Sherlock is making himself ill it's all
about bringing him and John back
together exploiting John's role as a
doctor to heal and care for others to
restore their partnership which is also
a major part of the story in the dying
detective as well and I just love how
this episode adapts these short stories
ending which had John himself hiding in
a hospital room and eavesdropping while
Smith confessed his crime and the
episode updated this to a metonymy of
John his walking stick doing the East
drop in with a hidden recording device
inside it was also pretty impressive for
Sherlock to stay one step ahead of Smith
by adding a force device saying she's
coming comforting about three people who
give up cuffed three now a lot of fans
are wondering that this might be a clue
that instead of three episodes which are
typical for the seasons there might be
an extra fourth episode as a bonus we
will see okay moving on to a later scene
where John reveals that it is Sherlock's
birthday so for years fans have
speculated that Sherlock's birthday was
on January 6th the reasoning was that in
the short stories there were some key
moments where Sherlock references
Shakespeare's Twelfth Night and that
refers to the Twelfth Night of Christmas
or January 6 now this episode aired on
January 8th implying that this theory
might be true and real quick as Mycroft
and lady Smallwood straighten up after
getting some which was teased with a
clever Archer style jump cut from
earlier from how much
do that sex I'm sorry if you look
closely you can see my Crocs notebook
and a handwritten list of Sherlock's
boltholes
hideout from his last vow the blind
green house at Penn Gardens the leaning
tomb at Hampstead Cemetery and the clock
space of Elizabeth power also known as
Big Ben but let's move on to this final
scene with the big reveal dat john
therapist the woman posing as safe smith
and ii the woman from the bus whom John
was having a text affair with we're all
the same woman URIs home Sherlock and
Mycroft's secret sister now Sherlock
Holmes scholar apparently that the thing
has speculated about the existence of a
third home sibling a brother who likely
had the name of Sharon Ford which was
Conan Doyle's original name for Sherlock
and then in his last vow there was my
crops mysterious line and must give him
to a brotherly compassion know what
happened to the other one so that moment
combined with Mycroft calling Sharon
Ford at the end of last episode it all
pretty much confirmed that we would be
seeing this third legendary home sibling
and many people hope that Tom Hiddleston
would pop up in the role but this show
is cleverer than that with Mycroft
saying the other one meaning it could be
a brother or a sister and this sister
isn't named Sharon Ford but URIs
explaining the II that she went by as a
woman on the bus I'm thinking Sharon
Ford may be the code name that Mycroft
has given her or could refer to a
facility that she was in more on that in
a second but first notice what she tells
John as the origin of the name York City
name is made Greek means leash Eastwind
now the words the east wind are a
callback to his last Val
where we heard Mycroft alley mr.
Sherlock between
coming child gotta kick and then
Sherlock repeated this later - John he's
went excellent man okay
just doing my brother talking with kids
he's doing this terrifying force but
lays waste to him in his path seeks out
the unworthy unplug them from the earth
that's generally me and then John
mentioned it a third time in reference
to Moriarty's return at the end of the
episode what if he is it's been a
wrap-up wolf
there's a nice clean together so it's
now clear that this east wind is
referring to URIs home and I'm thinking
that she might be the girl who we see in
here with young Sherlock and the dog red
beard in Sherlock memory
I assume next episode will reveal more
about the backstory but I'm going to
make a guest here and you could rather
not hear it skip to this time and case
it ends up coming true and it's an
accidental spoiler my theory is that
when they were kids
URIs might have done something to
traumatize Sherlock
like maybe she freaked everyone out by
killing the dog red beard which could
have haunted Sherlock and becoming the
sociopath yes today whatever it is I'm
thinking that she was taken away from
her brother's into a facility perhaps
called Charon Ford with her growing up
to be this dangerous imprisoned criminal
mastermind like Hannibal Lecter or
something which might explain why
Mycroft old lady Smallwood Jones should
yes sure I don't know as you can see
this is all kind of like unorganized
mind Palace prediction gunk obviously
we'll wait to see if next episode proves
me right on any of it and before I get
to this final literal shot there are a
few things I just love about this whole
scene first notice now John mistakenly
assumed Sherlock's sibling is a man not
a woman which parallels Sherlock making
the same mistake in the first episode of
study in pink assuming that the named
Harry referred to a brother it's not his
sister Harriet also as Eurus begins to
reveal the truth we see a shot of her as
a Smith walking normally then
transforming into using a cane in slow
motion which seems like a reversal of
the end of the usual suspects where
spoiler alert Keyser söze reveals
himself to us by walking with a limp and
then walking normally also she tells
John that a mutual friend put her in
touch with culverton Smith and the
secret message of Miss me on the note
indicates that like Vivian or Barry and
perhaps every major villain in the show
sees an associate of James Moriarty and
this final shot is a mirror of the
opening shot fading into red like a
double-oh-seven opener and really I
don't think anyone believes John
actually got shot in the face here the
close-up on The Smoking Gun
intentionally leaves it vague so that
you can't see exactly who fired this gun
or where it's pointed and all this
combined with the fact that John shows
up in the trailer for next episode yeah
this obviously isn't the end of John
Watson okay thanks for watching and let
me know what you think in the comments
and make sure to check out my breakdown
of last episode the six thatcher's and
keep an eye out for my breakdown of the
finale the final problem and please hit
like and subscribe to new rockstars and
share this video with all your friends
you can also contribute to us on patreon
thanks so much to all of our donors
especially
hopper if you aren't currently a patron
we would love your support you can hit
me up on Twitter with any series or
thoughts that you have about Sherlock
@ea boss or you can follow a new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars for
updates on when our videos are coming
out alright thanks for watching spice
[Music]